modern warfare 2's worldwide reveal gets
an official date and battlefield 2042
season 1 reveal might be coming next
week
the big world premiere of call of duty
modern warfare 2 is close so close it's
less than a week away on june 8th in an
effort to build further hype for the
game activision released a live action
trailer that shows a group of soldiers
task force 141 preparing to go behind
enemy lines the teaser ends with text
that reads the ultimate weapon is team
however it should have said the ultimate
weapon is steam i say this because
charlie intel recently spotted modern
warfare 2 artwork on steam and many are
taking this as a sign that the franchise
might make its way back to valve's
platform at some point in the future the
page containing the artwork has now
seemingly been updated to remove the
modern warfare 2 imagery but don't give
up hope just yet steam's twitter account
further fueled the speculation earlier
today by quote tweeting the new modern
warfare 2 teaser trailer along with the
eyes emoji while still not quite an
official confirmation it now seems all
but guaranteed that you can expect to
find modern warfare 2 on steam and while
we're on the subject of steam valve has
announced a delay for the steam deck
docking station due to a shortage of
parts luckily those who have pre-ordered
a steam deck like me don't have to worry
about the dock's delay impacting any
timelines as they use parts from
different factories heading back to the
fps news according to tom henderson
battlefield 2042's long-awaited season 1
update will be revealed officially next
week the reveal could happen possibly
with an accompanying trailer on june 7th
with impressions from media and other
sources going live on june 8th henderson
reported that play tests for season 1
have been going on extensively over the
past few weeks and one big change in
season 1 could be around specialists as
fans know 2042 did away with the
traditional class-based battlefield
approach in favor of specialist
characters the extent of any changes to
the system in the season 1 update are
unknown but henderson said a new
specialist character named evelina elise
could arrive in the new season
battlefield 2042's post-launch content
has been scaled back so dice could focus
on improving the game's core issues
additionally some developers have
already shifted to the next battlefield
game which could launch in 2024 as for
when season 1 might launch henderson
said it's on tap for release in the next
two weeks are you still playing
battlefield 2042 if so how often let me
know in the comments and if military
games aren't your thing and you somehow
made it this far into the video you
might be happy to know that bioware has
officially revealed the title for the
next dragon age game the new entry in
the series will be called dragon age
dread wolf confirming a strong
connection to a well-known character in
dragon age lore and though the game is
named after an established character the
studio said newcomers to the dragon age
world will still be able to understand
his schemes as they play the game and
although it isn't releasing in 2022
bioware promised we'll see more of
dragon age dread wolf sometime later
this year hit the comment section and
rank all of the dragon age games for me
and i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you